some people are pro-vaxx
some people are anti-backs if I ever
find one of these lying around again I
will stop being so polite get the
out of my sight before I demolish you
and some people are anti anti-facts
that is the group today that we take on
in the viral
anti-anti-vaxx tick tocks you know that
I am not on Tick Tock I think I have an
account but I don't run it I don't even
think I have the app on my phone
somebody else runs it over here with
daily wire please help me I have not
slept in three days so I need my
producers to bring me the absolute
tippity-top tickety talks and they have
done that take it away I don't know the
long-term effects okay why can't you
just respect my choice if you want to
get the vaccine that's fine if I don't
want to get it
huh I don't want to get the vaccine
I don't want to drive out to the airport
twice I don't want to have someone stick
a needle in my arm twice and I don't
want to experience any of the potential
side effects twice
so so why are you getting it then yeah
the Healthcare System actually wants me
to get it because if not enough of us do
what's going to happen is we're going to
open up covert's going to spread
everywhere no one's going to have any
protection the healthcare system is
going to collapse people who need help
won't be able to get it and lots of
people are going to die
I disagree you should still respect my
choice well it's a selfish choice so I
don't you should still respect my choice
this just comes from a misunderstanding
on the part of the left of what the
conservatives are actually saying and in
part I think it's because conservatives
were inarticulate in expressing why we
opposed the fauci ouchy surprise
get that gun out of my face and the
experimental drug being Unleashed on
five and a half billion people in the
world the argument that a lot of
conservatives made was he lives whatever
happened to my body my choice well when
it comes to the vaccine I'm just going
to say the same line that you say about
abortion and I'm going to say my body my
choice
but conservatives
only say that
ironically
or at least they should only be saying
that ironically we are making fun of the
Liberals pro-abortion argument the
Liberals and abortions say my body my
choice but we don't really believe that
that's not a good argument for abortion
so we say oh whatever happened to my
body my choice that's basically just
like saying hey you guys you left us
you're a bunch of Hypocrites so I'm not
going to go along with that but we're
not actually saying that we have this
total bodily autonomy whether or not
you've got another human being in your
body or not there are plenty of things
that individuals are not and should not
be allowed to do with their bodies
shouldn't be able to shoot up heroin
shouldn't be able to kill yourself
shouldn't be able to in my opinion get
like a bunch of really stupid tattoos
and die your hair a crazy color and look
like a big lip but probably the law
won't catch up with my preferences there
at least on the first two though we have
all sorts of laws that tell you that you
do not have total autonomy to do
whatever you want to your own body that
is not it is not a conservative idea to
say that we can do whatever we want with
our own bodies that's a very liberal
idea conservatives instead believe no we
don't own our bodies we didn't create
our bodies we didn't create our own
lives that actually life is a gift from
God and that we owe certain uh
obligations
to God uh particularly vis-a-vis the
moral order the reason not to get the
fauci ouchi is because it's an
experimental drug made up by the worst
people on Earth to stop a virus that for
the vast majority of people is not that
dangerous and because it's a horrible
reordering of our political Community
that's why my body my choice is not the
argument keep going
[Music]
walking up to your door
you and I are over now
seems like a little bit of a cope from
my perspective from this lady
if I were a Gambling Man I would bet
that the reason that her ex-boyfriend is
her ex-boyfriend is that he got a new
girlfriend or that he found her to be a
little bit
crazy you're jealous you're manipulative
it's crazy
call me crazy
it wasn't working out and my evidence
for this is that she is behaving like a
crazy lady in this video and she's
expressing views that are crazy and
she's on Tick Tock to begin with which
is uh not right she doesn't even have
basic Motors functions anymore that
would be my guess and now she's now
she's trying to justify that but if that
was the reason if she actually dumped
her boyfriend because he wouldn't take
the experimental mRNA therapy dodged a
bullet buddy that you dodged two bullets
buddy you dodged the pouchy bullet and
you dodged the lady bullet more on that
in just one second first though head on
over to expressvpn.com Michael YT it is
extremely important to protect your
online privacy with a VPN choosing a VPN
that you trust is equally as important
expressvpn is my favorite VP and it is
super easy to install on all of my
devices phone laptop you can put it on
your tablet you click one button you are
protected extremely straightforward and
I can say with full confidence that
expressvpn is the best VPN on the market
number one expressvpn doesn't log your
online activity they've developed a
trusted server technology makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can even stream HD videos
with zero buffering three expressvpn is
incredibly easy to use just fire up the
app and tap one button to connect it's
not just me saying this Business Insider
The Verge and many other Tech journals
write expressvpn the number one VPN in
the world protect yourself with the VPN
I trust use expressvpn.com Michael YT
today get three months free in a
one-year package
expresvpn.com
michaelyt expressvpn.com Michael y t hi
I'm Pam and this is my partner teller
you may have heard vaccination causes
autism in one out of 110 children
that total it doesn't but let's
imagine it does we'll compare two groups
of children teller's group gets no
vaccinations my group I'll use this
Plexiglas to represent the vaccinations
oh that's bad my vaccination wall
knocked one of the children out of line
that's our one in 110 with autism in the
1920s before the diphtheria vaccination
was common there were 13 to 15 000
deaths a year from that disease if
you've got it your chances of dying were
about 40 percent
in 1952 just before the salt vaccine
became common there were about 58 000
cases of polio if you get unlucky you
might end up permanently disabled or
dead
meningitis Hepatitis A and B flu lumps
whooping cough pneumonia rotavirus
rubella smallpox tetanus chickenpox
chickenpox we have vaccinations against
all of them which side do you want your
child to stand
so even if vaccination did cause autism
which it doesn't
anti-vaccination would still be
sounds really scientific doesn't it yeah
these these people seem like they're on
the right side the evidence is so in
their favor that they have to yell and
scream and throw oranges at a bunch of
bowling pins use all sorts of
profanities that total
because all of the evidence in the
arguments are on their side right I
don't think so how do we know that when
pendulite comes out and says there's
nothing wrong don't do anything bad
they're only great they're wonderful
there's no question about them
whatsoever how do we know beyond this
insane performance that that doesn't
quite tell the whole story well we know
because there's a vaccine Adverse Events
database established by the US Congress
we know because their vaccine courts
that actually award sums of money to
people who suffer vaccine injuries we
know that no medical procedure including
a vaccine maybe especially a vaccine is
without risk we think vaccines are
that's the one medical procedure that
there's no risk whatsoever but the other
reason we know that this doesn't tell
the whole story
is what he said at the end he says
whooping cough diphtheria polio there's
that chickenpox he's throwing the orange
at the bowling pins as if chickenpox
killed 40 percent of people that were
infected with it when you and I know
people who are my age maybe a little bit
younger and everyone else who's older
knows that chickenpox is not a big deal
everyone used to get Chickenpox and it
was totally fine parents would take
their kids to chickenpox parties so all
the kids would get Chickenpox at once
and the worst thing that happened was
maybe you get a Mark or two on your face
Maybe probably not even that and you
have to rub some kind of lotion on you
and take a special bath and you were
totally fine did you say okay I know
that they're lying about the chickenpox
part or they may be lying and
exaggerating all the rest of it too this
isn't our fault okay this isn't the
people who are skeptical of the public
health establishment it's not our fault
we're not the ones who out of nowhere
constructed the tinfoil hats and started
questioning everything baselessly they
lied to us for three years specifically
about the covet bags scene they lied to
our faces the most charitable take is
that they just happened to get
everything wrong and probably the more
realistic take is that there were people
who were lying who were not running the
proper tests who are rushing this thing
through who were downplaying the side
effects who were overplaying the
efficacy they were just dishonest the
whole time
and so when we don't believe you anymore
in particular about this category of
medical procedure called vaccines that's
not our fault that's your fault you want
our trust back earn our trust back but I
don't have any Trust
in in that establishment anymore next
one the mat's fake IDs how can I help
you yo you guys make those fake vaccine
cards we sure do they're one of our top
sellers can I get one of those of course
government's not going to tell me what
to do with my body I'm not a woman
uh-huh damn liberals uh okay well I'm
just gonna need a photo ID and a credit
card and I can get this order started
for you oh right
what who's that oh Samuel he comes in
all the time for fake work papers that
is not okay yeah he uses them to help
undocumented workers good job you can't
fake documents like that there are rules
in this country but aren't you doing
that it's totally different they're
trying to support their families I'm
trying to trick my peers into having
them think that I'm vaccinated against a
severe disease so I can still get into
bars
oh you yes severe disease so this
is a young man saying this is a severe
disease this disease poses statistically
zero percent threat to him it might be
severe for some people it's certainly
not severe for a young man the severe
risk from covet for young people is
negligible not quite the same could be
said about the vaccine but but you see
the premise of it the premise is well
this guy
is fine with certain fake documents but
not other fake documents see he's a
hypocrite no they're different documents
the argument that he's making well those
are different things that's actually a
good argument not all documents are the
same right I have a pass to my local
public pool and I've got a copy of
mineconf I guess they're both documents
but they're different right the
substance of those documents is
different and so in the case of getting
a fake vaccine card I think one could
make a pretty strong argument that to
possess such a car depending on the
circumstances would be morally
acceptable you are resisting a deeply
unjust law that mandates a vaccine that
is in its very production cooperating to
some degree with evil so you can make
make that argument to say okay this is a
deeply immoral law and it's not wrong
for me to disobey that law whereas for a
work permit or a voting card or a
driver's license or something like you
can't make the same argument there are
different documents man not very
persuasive tick tocks I'm still very
glad that I am off
the platform see you next time
[Music]